the only thing that can be sure of about
the future is it it will be absolutely
fantastic hello everybody welcome to
this special episode of in do the
impossible recently the University of
California San Diego Institute for the
arts and humanities
commemorated the 100th birthday of Prima
levy with a symposium remembering his
life and the example he said of uniting
scientific and literary cultures primo
Levy was a chemist a writer and a
survivor of Auschwitz he said that
stitching together molecules taught him
to stitch together words and ideas this
episode of into the impossible is
dedicated to the memory of Primo levy
today we're gonna have a conversation
with dr. Luka linyanti he's a research
fellow at the Scripps Institute and he
studies among other things the origins
of life and how that is affected by the
chirality of molecules so why don't you
introduce yourself tell us a little bit
about you and how I get into this work
yeah hi everybody
yes my name is Luca la yaani and this is
the the field and I'm studying so I'm a
post doctoral fellow in the in the group
of professor Blackman and what we are
trying to understand or to collect more
evidences about is the general picture
is the origin of life so our life
started on our planet and more
specifically oh I was the origin of Homo
chirality so why the molecules that are
part of our body and part of the body of
of many living organisms why they have a
specific chirality and now these started
so look at you you're obviously Italian
Primo Levi was Italian so you
you know about him what was it about his
work that inspired you
yeah well prema levy is very famous in
in Italy and worldwide mainly because of
his work about the Holocaust during the
Second World War but prema lady was also
chemist and the he was inspired by
chemistry so you wrote many short
stories about about chemistry and I'm
pretty sure I would say that also with
his short stories with his writing yours
inspired different generations of
chemists for sure in Italy but I'm also
pretty sure worldwide tell us about how
your work intersects with this interest
you had in prima Livy well Olivia wrote
probably regarding chemistry's most
famous book is the periodic table in
which he has differential stories and
every story is dedicated to a specific
element of the periodic table but we
don't have to forget that also primal ad
was one of the main other big topic he
was interested about was also region of
life that's a little bit the branch of
research I am I'm involved too so he
wrote for example the short stories his
own maker that was published in 1971 in
which Prima levy images to have such a
long memory by which you can go back in
the past and look at the different
stages and path that brought a simple
bacteria's evolving to more complex
animals also bringing it to the form of
of a human another interesting short
stories for example carbon that was also
published in the in the seventies and in
the short olds carbon he takes the
molecule it takes an atom of carbon and
he follows it into different into
different stages so in the atmosphere as
a molecule of carbon dioxide then ending
up in the
in a plan for example or indifferent
animals the literature the writing and
the metaphors and the the style of his
writing inspired a lot of science a lot
of a lot of scientific investigation I
think it's both ways so it's for sure as
you're saying these is writing
interested many chemists many scientists
and for sure many have been inspired by
his work and also the other way around
so primo levy was as I said it was a
good chemist and he well knew what was
going on in the scientific community and
more specifically in the in the
chemistry community so he was also it
took inspiration for many of these short
stories by the scientific discoveries
and by reaction elements and molecules
and we can find them in many of the of
the short stories you wrote so here's a
one-year slide that talks about the
carbon cycle yeah exactly the short
story is carbon that was published in
the in the seventies in 1975 follows the
the journey of an atom of carbon as I
said into different living organisms
such as plants animals but also in as an
nonliving matter so for example in the
atmosphere as carbon dioxide or in the
ground and yeah in the 70s also other
authors were interested in in the origin
of life so for example Carl Sagan as in
the in the first slide try to imagine
the origin of life in any condense the
the story of the of the of the universe
in a one-year calendar and the condense
at the origin of life only in one one
month so right here at UCSD we have a
legacy which was the famous miller-urey
experiment which is trying to prove
abiogenesis right that life could have
came from physical
processes yeah Miller and Urey were they
later on became professor here at UCSD
and they were the first that could
confirm the hypothesis of operands
operon was this Russian biochemist and
he was the first one who suggested that
molecules could grow into more complex
structure and more complex molecules and
meaner than Yuri that's what they could
they could prove so basically they took
some sort of these apparatus and they
started refluxing and applying
electrical charges to a mixture of
inorganic and simple matter cells in
organic molecules such as for example
methane ammonia hydrogen and by
refluxing under warm temperature for
many days after analyzing the content of
these of these apparatus they could find
more complex molecules such as for
example amino acids so this was the
first time that somebody could prove a
little-bitty
hypothesis that was formulated like 30
years before by operon by this Russian
biochemist so do you by it I mean is a
is is a biogenesis something that has
been proven there more evidence for or
less definitely more evidence so since
the experiment in the 50s by Miller and
Urey ors for more even more complex
molecules have been built into
conditions that are called prebiotic ly
plausible so like into for example
warming them up and by applying them
electrical charges so yeah even more
evidences have been collected since the
since the 50s for sure the experiment of
malaria is the the most famous one but
there are even even even more so so your
work gets gets more into this shown on
this slide which is the the concept of
chirality or the handedness of molecules
so first tell us what chirality is yes
karati it's what interesting
but again it's also a big topic about
which Premila viewers who was very
interested and it was so interested that
he also wrote is master disease as an
undergraduate student at the University
of Turin
so chirality is actually or well we can
describe an object as being chiral when
it it's not possible to superimpose it
on its mirror image so the classical
example that chemists used to describe a
chiral object is the example of one hand
because if we take for example the right
hand the mirror image of it it's going
to be a left hand but we cannot
superimpose the two images one onto the
one onto the other so also for this for
this reason we usually speak about right
hand and left hand molecule another easy
example can be also the one of a chair
so if we take a normal chair this is a
non chiral object because we can take
the mirror image here and superimpose
onto it but on the other hand if we take
a chair like a conference chair with a
side table on the side in this case we
cannot superimpose the image of this
kind of a chair on to its mirror image
so in this case we are in the presence
of a chiral object and chirality is an
extremely important property in
chemistry because if we have an atom of
carbon that's the fundamental atom in
the molecules of life and this atom of
carbon is connected to four different
group of atoms or to four different
molecules then we are in the presence of
a chiral molecule and it's very very
important because usually it interacts
with living organisms in two different
ways according if we are using a
right-hand chiral molecule or a left one
so very famous for example example of
chiral molecules are the one of solid
amide so right side amide was
commercialized
many years ago like in the fifties if
not wrong and it was commercialized as
as a drug to fight the Indonesia in a
pregnant women the only problem is that
the molecule that was active that was
having the benefit of combating this
nose effect was the right-hand molecule
and the problem the main problem was
that this kind of molecule was not
commercialized as a pure so it was not
just commercialized a right-hand
molecule but because it's just easier to
prepare which goes for cost less it was
commercialized as a racemic mixture so
50 percent of the right form molecule
and 50 percent of the left 4 molecule
and the left molecule was then was has
been seen that was causing teratogenic
effect on to the babies that was
pregnant women were waiting for so just
to be clear about it there's no
difference in the physical properties of
the molecule exactly exactly the same
melting point boiling point same solute
properties same you know chemical
formulas chemical for table example
number exactly you're right they are
they have the same physical chemical
properties so these part of the this
part this combines why they are so
interesting and also so difficult to
work with so the main difference is that
they interact in a different way with
other chiral molecules so that's why
living organisms that are full of chiral
molecules they if we take other carbon
molecules we are going to see them
interacting in a different way with for
example with our with our body with the
body of the living organisms so here's
another example
yeah exactly this is the other example
so methamphetamine the left form of the
of the molecule is sold as an
over-the-counter drug as a nasal
decongestant so this kind of molecule
can be easily both in
many pharmacies what is not so easy to
get your hands on is actually the right
form of this molecule because the right
form of methamphetamine has actually
effect as a recreational drug so if you
want to get these then you will have to
ask for example yeah Walter White in the
in the very famous TV series Breaking
Bad to prepare this for you
so prema levy was a good chemist and he
knew that in a chemical reaction so if
we are if you want to prepare like a
product formed by the left and the
molecule and the right hand molecule if
we are in the absence of a chiral
template so if we don't have any chiral
molecules into our reaction mixture what
we are going to prepare is a so called a
racemic mixture so 50 percent of the
left 4 molecule and 50 percent of the
right 4 molecule but in the other hand
if we are in the presence of a chiral
template so of a chiral molecule we are
going to pre to to be in the present so
it's possible it's no not always
occurring but it can be that we are
forming 60% of one molecule and 40% of
the other or to the point where we are
in the with 99% of em left molecule and
1% of the right one and how this part
are very interesting where they're
linked together with the region of life
is because as I was mentioning before
our body and the body of mostly all the
living organisms are formed by chiral
molecules so for example all the sugars
that we are using are in the right-hand
form and the amino acid that we are were
using are in the left and form so for
example amino acid forming protein or
sugars that are part of DNA and RNA
but now the the big question that again
prima lady was asking himself in the
short stories asymmetry in life is how
it's possible that starting from simple
molecules we could form only one hand
form of them
molecules so the question is not if we
can take water idrija and methane
methane for example and bring and
forming four amino acids because that
was as we discussed before was proven
already by Miller and Urey but the point
is that how at the origin of of the
universe if we didn't have any chiral
template in it why life is formed by one
hundred percent one form of the hand
molecule so again why why we are in the
presence only of right sugar and the
left amino acid and not the other way
around so why we don't have like a
racemic racemic mixture in the living
organism or why we don't have the other
way around why we don't have less sugar
and right amino acid for example that's
also the the very big and general
question chemist now it is in order to
address this question they divided this
process that would have potentially
brought to the formation of again last
amino acid and right sugar and all the
other molecules into different stats so
from a condition in the plant in where
we had a racemic mixture so 50 percent
each of the two molecule we need some
events that would bring to an an
unchurched the form of the two molecules
so as symmetry breaking so going from
fifty fifty to fifty one forty nine then
following this step we would have to
increase this kind of imbalance that
were formed so going from 5149 to maybe
let's call it ninety percent and and
then how these molecules here were once
they are enriched to this level how they
are finally reached to the one hundred
percent form of again for example in
this case right sugar and the last amino
acid and now this chiral information is
even transferred into more complex
molecule such as DNA or proteins one of
the idea for what concern for example
the first step the symmetry breaking was
already
published discoveries in the seventies
so it it has been seen that if we take
for example a racemic mixture of these
amino acid valine so 50% of each and if
we are irrigating this mixture with left
circularly polarized light we are going
to degrade this mixture but we are not
going to degrade the two molecules at
the same way so at the end of the
process we are going to be in the
presence of a little bit more of the
left form of the amino acid versus the
right form so it's not a big difference
is going to be just 1% but is important
to start the whole process what's
interesting is that left circle
circularly polarized light was not
probably present present in the
prebiotic world but what has been
discovered is that from the space dust
that is falling on our on our planet
some amino acid are a little bit an
antigen reached so there is a little bit
more of the left form of these amino
acid again is not a big amount is just
like few few points percentage of this
ee
that's a parameter that chemists used to
describe the chirality but this is also
pretty fascinating because it's it might
suggest that the region of life actually
as an origin out of our planet part of
the for what comes from the second steps
there are different processes that have
been described that have been discussed
many of them for example taking account
different crystallization processes so
crystallization is a purification matter
that all the other chemists using there
in their lab to purify molecules but
they also might be involved in this
process of growing these imparied this
imparity in the in the mixture of right
and left left molecules so for example
if we take suspension in which there is
in which there are amino
see derivative in the disorder in the
Indus oven so in solution but also in
equilibrium with their solid form if we
start from a little bit of an imbalance
so from 51 for example of the left form
of there's 49 of the other one and if we
start steering very in a very vigorous
way this kind of suspension after few
days we are going to be in the presence
of 60% and 40% of the other form so we
are growing into these imbalance and if
we keep steering our suspension for even
more days at for example after 2 weeks
we are going to be in the presence of
only the left form of the amino acid so
this is for example an experiment that
would suggest how it's possible to go
from a 51/49 imbalance into a much
bigger one the last step of all of this
process is also out to connect all of
those reaction so how all of these
reactions communicated together to bring
at the end the the molecules that are
forming life so again
for example sugar into DNA and amino
acid into protein so we had what we are
doing for example right now is to take
molecules such as amino nitrous that are
likely to be present in our preview tic
hurt and if we have a racemic mixture of
them and if we are if we are inducing
them two basic condition we are going to
form amino acid derivative in a 50 50
percent mixture so in a racemic mixture
but if we again if we in this kind of
reaction we are in the presence of a
chiral molecule and not as a random one
but right sugars what we are going to
form is more of the left form of the
amino acid so why do you think this
happens is it it sound it seems like
there's there's physical processes that
tend towards this handedness with with
no enzymatic
no bioactive process that needs to
happen yeah exactly
mmm one of the in these in these
hypotheses in these reactions that we
are working on we we think that
enzymatic reactions were not quite there
because that that point was like much
forward in the origin of life pathways
so all of these reactions and and and
and processes they actually are
occurring because of the interaction of
current molecules that were already
there so starting again as I showed in
the in the presentation so starting from
this little imbalance its then enough to
have a little bit more of one form of
the current molecule to give the to
bring this current information and to
propagate it into into different
molecules so in your lab how do you
study this
how are you breaking this down we have
different reactions different processes
that we are that we are studying one for
example I show it right now it's taking
is understanding how sugars and amino
acids are communicating together because
again also how this chiral information
is transferred to a different molecule
so again in this case the two most
important ones so sugars an amino acid
there are also different studies in
which they involve the polymerization
for example of amino acid into more
complex structures that are called
peptides and now for example the current
information of peptides is also
transferred to other reactions and this
this last slide you have it's it's kind
of asking it's kind of begging the
question we started with yes because the
the the origin of life is of course it's
part of a big picture and the the origin
of Homo chirality that's what we
discussed today can also maybe help us
to address our original fly for cures so
if you took cured by a sea
winds of preordained events so in a
deterministic view or as a series of
random events in a stochastic point of
view of course we can also not exclude
that intelligent design played the role
in the origin of life but yet as
scientists we feel that this would be
pretty boring games were to give and in
an in your career what is what's got you
excited where do you want this to lead I
think for example there is much more to
do for what control sticking to a region
of life or what concern for example the
different metals so metal catalysis is
actually a big big field in organic
chemistry but I have a feeling that many
the role of different metals into the
reactions at the origin of life and not
has not been studied enough so this
would be for example was a big big
picture to try to to get more of an idea
about I would see simple simple methods
so iron our copper of these metals at
the the role at the idea region of our
of our planet at the origin of life on
the only health so we just had a tour of
our cosmology lab and he saw the polar
bear telescope and he saw the small
aperture telescope that's headed for the
Simon's Observatory where we're looking
at polarity of the universe's oldest
light the CMB or Cosmic Microwave
Background
how do you feel about that did you see
some some comparisons some parallels to
your work yeah I would say definitely
like the polarized light might of course
as an influence in the in the indicator
in the chirality that then is part of
our of life of life of our life and of
life of the of the living organisms so
there are many many many possible
connections I think it's it's a matter
of understanding if also the
the energy of life is like enough to to
be transferred and to a process to a
reactions where would imbalance again I
will repeat a little bit myself but if
it's able to imbalance into one
direction or the other
our a cynic mixer so again if we are in
the presence of a 50% 50% a mixture of
the two molecules if we if these dis
light is possibly inducing the either
the degradation of one or the other one
or the formation of one process versus
the other to go in the either one or the
other direction well look I want to
thank you for being any to the
impossible thanks for the opportunity
giving us some insight into your work
and into the work and life of Primo Levi
in celebration of his 100th birthday
imagination UCSD edu for the arthur c--
clark center for human imagination I'm
Stewart Waldo thank you for listening
the only thing we can be sure of about
the future is it will be absolutely
[Music]
you
you